welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
mania's post-credit reveals are now
known to the world but there is a major
detail from the Kang Dynasty that we
haven't really discussed yet Kang
variant Pharaoh Rama Tut isn't just an
Egyptian ruler he is part Android
robotic arms a robotic torso beneath the
rib cage cruelly depriving audiences of
the Men's Health eye candy they came to
see so is this still Rama Tut and if so
what the hell happened to him how was he
still alive and what do these three
kings physical conditions tell us about
the past Wars that they fought I'm
actually digging into quantumania even
deeper today on our second Channel The
Deep dive Please Subscribe and enjoy
that analysis and you can't support our
growing Network by grabbing some
merchand nerd riot.shop like one of
these vasmanat designs from our deep
dive collection okay of the three kings
we first meet in the quantumania
mid-credits scene Rama Tut has arguably
the most personality he's the only one
of the three with visible cheek scars
which he owns by painting gold and he
Sports a smirk as he taunts the other
king it must really eat you update
you're not the one who killed him eats
you up a fitting Choice Awards for a
Kang Varian who looks like his lower
half was devoured by scarab beetles
Now Fair aromatet in the comics was one
of the earliest time travel villains
that was later retconned ascang a
villain to the Fantastic Four but it
looks like some changes have been made
to this Rama Tut he carries a staff
topped by an ankh and his arms and Laura
torso are all cybernetic metal rather
than a metallic shell or a covering like
what Bucky's vibranium Winter Soldier
arm looks like it looks like they
covered Jonathan Major's body with a
green suit to key out his body and
replace it with empty space to show that
his flesh and organs are no longer there
our man has been reconstructed with
metallic Parts his arm actually looks
like the black and yellow stripes of the
Winter Soldier vibranium arm the more
recent one from Infinity War onward most
recently seen the guardian's holiday
special when nebula randomly gifted it
to Rocket but past Rama Tut's bicep it
actually looks like they might have used
some of his original bones like perhaps
his actual ulna and radius or maybe
synthetic Replacements but either way
motorized by cybernetic Parts his torso
meanwhile is completely non-existent
just a striped shell that matches his
headpiece covering his rib cage area and
beneath a metallic like spine that
connects to the hip no clue where his
lungs are his diaphragm his liver his
intestines his kidneys no idea how he's
alive but you know kanks have Superior
technology and he might actually be all
robotic underneath just using synthetic
human tissue over the top like the
Terminator or perhaps similar to the
tissue that Ultron created enriched with
vibranium atoms that eventually became
Vision but bringing up Ultron a vision
actually makes us wonder if this Kang
could be using the same Android or
synthazoid Tech that those guys use we
just saw Ultron sentries with similar
Hardware in the Baxter Foundation of
Multiverse Madness my leading theory of
late has been that Avengers Tower is
currently occupied by a cane variant Mr
Griffin of King Enterprises and that's
why we saw it pruned in the TVA void and
I believe we saw Mr Griffin in his trim
CEO suit teleporting to the Dynasty's
Coliseum floor this could all point to
Kings acquiring all available Stark Tech
and in ramadet's case be used to augment
his broken body he who remains told us
that before the multiversal war broke
out all Nathaniel Richards variants or a
Time supporting each other and shared
resources ratio technology
knowledge using the best of their
universes to improve the others but we
should also ask what
Ms ramitet's Android but Parts is it
vibranium like ultron's final form and
if so that would give the King Dynasty a
perhaps greater stink in the coming
vibranium War coming out of black
panther we're kind of forever what Val
was seeking in the coming plots of
Captain America New World Order and
Thunderbolts which are still rumored to
revisit the corpse of the celestial
teammate using it as a minable resource
being fought over by the nations of
Earth but what if this medal is
adamantium an even stronger alloy of
vibranium now we're talking I like
eating so much that I do it every day
but figuring out what to eat is a
different story and for that I Outsource
my decision making process to Hungry
root hungry root is a tech enabled
grocery service delivered right to your
door that's personalized to your
lifestyle and tastes you just take a
short quiz when you sign up sharing how
you like to eat your dietary needs and
your goals which can be anything from
eating more plants to just saving time
in the kitchen hungry root then sends
you personalized weekly deliveries
filled with healthy groceries you can
edit your weekly deliveries and choose
exactly what you'd like to receive or
let hungry root choose for you when your
delivery arrives at your doorstep you
can mix and match the groceries with
what's in your fridge or use the easy 10
minute recipes hungry root provides with
over 2 000 recipes to try you'll never
get bored with your meals the more you
shop and cook with hungry root the more
the personalization engine learns what
you like so you can spend less time
planning shopping and cooking and just
more time enjoying the food that you
love this week I got a ton of stuff I
got stuff for some pasta some stuff for
a pesto grilled cheese but I unboxed it
at the perfect time because I was able
to pop in the microwave a simple and
delicious breakfast tamale
oh God I love a good tamale I love good
breakfast this is both the first 100
people to use my code rockstars40 will
get 40 off your first grocery order with
hungry root use the link in the
description or go to hungryroot.com and
use the code rockstars40 to get 40 off
this Kang Rama Tut could be sporting the
metallic skeleton of a Marvel hero that
he killed in the past a kind of trophy
taken from that hero a hero who might
have snicked ripped him in half and left
him like this Wolverine now if this were
just Rama Tut our minds would simply go
to the Egyptian corner of the MCU and
suspect that he has some history or
maybe a future history that we have yet
to see with Moon Knight in konshu we
have talked before about how Disney
Plus's Moon Knight series included our
first MCU shout outs to Kang Rama touch
shown up on the back of that kid's
jacket and Cairo and then a QR code in
the final episode that takes you to a
2019 Moon Knight acts of evil comic that
pits Moon Knight koncho against Kang
Moon Knight head writer Jeremy Slater
also said that they plan to have someone
mention ramatut by name in an episode
but that line got cut I suspect the MCU
will connect Rama Tut with Moon Knight
and some upcoming title maybe Avengers
King Dynasty the matchup obviously makes
sense but I think the fact that all of
these gangs are so eccentric and scarred
and unique ways tells us that these
aren't exactly the versions of Kang for
the comics these guys have all had very
specific past histories with a
combination of the Avengers like Kang
the Conqueror the Exile in the quantum
realm indicated that he's killed so many
Avengers that they start to blur
together after a while and he definitely
killed a Thor at some point these three
kings refer to the Avengers as they and
they probably also have killed alternate
universe Avengers and Marvel heroes in
the past and those battles are how they
got these scars and disfigured forms
immortus speaks with a dramatic croaked
whisper which made him compared to the
voice Jonathan Majors use when he voiced
that third timekeeper in Loki episode
four
the voice of a king who might have had
his trachea destroyed by being choked
for a lifetime of screaming then there's
that more futuristic King looks like
he's wearing that suit to best protect
himself from armored Iron Man or iron
hearts or black panthers or visions and
then ramatuts for him to be this messed
up it reminds us of Darth Vader after
Obi-Wan Kenobi High grounded him on that
Lava Beach on Mustafar if you need this
much reassembly that's not something you
can really do by yourself ramatat must
have gotten messed up and then other
kangs must have considered him so
valuable that his remaining parts are
worth preserving in this hybrid Android
form and so they decided to rebuild him
and keep him alive they need him this
tells us that ramatut must have some
precious knowledge or skill set but the
other two kings need to maintain power
over the Dynasty and control the other
timelines perhaps as one of the older
kings that can meet insights into the
Fantastic Four Moon Knight the idiot the
Gods of Earth the history of human
civilization at large the only King to
get so up by Marvel heroes and
live to tell the tale is extremely
valuable because he can tell the others
the exact weaknesses and pressure points
of each of these Marvel heroes that he
went 10 Rounds with how do you think
ramatud got this way and are we seeing
the first true adamantium skeleton in
the MCU and a reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and you
can support by grabbing some merch at
nerd riot.shop follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at eavos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]